carles desde luego estamos ante una
ocasión histórica los 70 años en el
trono de la reina isabel era una cosa
que no se podía esperar cuando se coronó
como reina siendo una mujer tan
jovencita desde luego está siendo una
jornada muy emocionante también llena de
primeras veces es la primera vez que la
reina celebra su jubileo sin su esposo
el duque de edimburgo a su lado está
haciendo desde luego un día muy emotivo
para los británicos pero también para
los amantes de la monarquía en todos los
rincones del mundo cómo han sido estos
70 años de reinado de isabel marina
es muy difícil esta pregunta porque es
prácticamente imposible definir a
1.072 claro setenta años de jefatura de
estado en unas pocas frases ha habido de
todo habido 14 primeros ministros
británicos que han gobernado en nombre
de su majestad la reina isabel en estos
70 años hemos vivido
la entrada del reino unido en la reunión
europea entonces comunidad económica
europea hemos vivido la salida del reino
unido de la unión europea hemos vivido
el huracán lady y hemos vivido este otro
huracán citó más pequeño de los duques
de esas ex han sido 70 años muy intensos
históricos y desde luego con con la
posibilidad que nos da la historia de
juzgar hacia atrás han sido 70 años con
muchas más luces que sombras
también le quiero preguntar a marina
puede ser como ha sido últimamente pues
estos días de la reina isabel segunda
sabemos que ya pues está en el castillo
windsor en su residencia oficial que ya
no es como lo era también de costumbre
pues la anfitriona del palacio de
bukingham si no es el príncipe guillermo
con su esposa kate middleton como ha
sido entonces estas transformaciones
digamos de la reina isabel segunda al
pasar de los años por supuesto ya tiene
96 años
efectivamente tenemos una soberana
anciana y hay que hacer ciertas aunque
parece que está en plena forma la
estamos viendo ahora en directo desde el
balcón de buckingham palace y desde
luego parece que está en plena forma
pero no podemos negar el paso del tiempo
su majestad tiene 96 años y ha habido
que ir haciendo ciertas adaptaciones
en lo que es su trabajo del día a día
porque su majestad trabaja todos los
días una de las más simbólicas digamos
ha sido abandonar el palacio de
buckingham es de palacio en el centro de
londres como residencia oficial y su
traslado al castillo de windsor a unos
pocos kilómetros a las afueras de
londres esto
ocurrió durante la pandemia y
bueno por proteger un poco a la reina
isabel y en aquel momento también al
duque de edimburgo dos personas de
avanzada edad y se decidió que iban a
estar más seguros más protegidos en
windsor con una corte muy pequeñita era
mucho más fácil de proteger que el gran
palacio de buckingham y ya la reina
después del fallecimiento en el castillo
de windsor del duque de edimburgo
decidió no volver a buckingham no no
hacerlo su residencia oficial es curioso
porque la reina nunca ha sido
le hagan amiga del palacio de buckingham
un poco el buque insignia de la
monarquía británica este palacio el
centro de londres
ella no nació en buckingham porque
recordemos que ella no nació como
heredera al trono de inglaterra sino que
ella era la sobrina del rey de aquel rey
que abdicó para poder casarse con wallis
simpson ella tiene una casa en un
palacete en piccadilly y nunca según sus
propias palabras nunca se ha llegado a
sentir verdaderamente
en el palacio de buckingham es más
muchas veces ha dicho ahora estamos
viendo cómo se retira la ha dicho que
buckingham era sus oficinas y windsor
era su casa